le net peu plus de 100 un tout petit peu
hâlé donne un petit mot à lui manquer
d'où ce sentiment s'est passé
genève
mais même avec en mx1
gênant que vous entendez là son état
civil
c'est rodolphe richeval mais son nom de
rappeur sénégalais ricol et ça a été
l'un de mes enseignants
je n'ai pas eu au collège ni au lycée ni
à la fac mais il m'a enseigné à travers
ses albums à travers ses concerts et à
travers ces projets de ce qu'on appelle
les mixtes et comment ce qui m'a
enseigné il m'a appris des choses sur
mon pays
il m'a appris des choses sur moi-même en
tant que jeune homme noir qui essayait
de se construit en guadeloupe et en
martinique neg lyrical pour moi a été
une espèce des toiles dans le ciel que
je regardais alors que j'essayais de me
comprendre
tu sais elle me trouve et je suis devenu
enseignant chercheur l'éducateur mais
j'ai été pétri dans le moule des
cultures urbaines
j'étais pétri dans ce monde là j'étais
fabriqués par cela et je dois vous
avouer que très souvent en plus de mon
travail à l'université je vais dans des
établissements scolaires et je vais à la
rencontre d'un jeune public qui lui est
complètement fasciné par ce monde là qui
est pétri aussi par ce monde et le temps
en temps j'y vais comme je suis
aujourd'hui
lorsque j'arrive souvent ya les
encadrants qui ne me dise pas mon jour
ils me regardent bizarrement hackers
moratti va pas s'aggraver
parce que ma dégaine est bizarre en quoi
mais je viens la rencontre des jeunes
on était habillé comme je m'habille
comme ça quand je sors une fois que je
vais à la fac
bon allez je n'ai pas la casquette à
l'envers fulham est à l'endroit mais je
le fais exprès pour faire tomber
certains préjugés tombent et certains
stéréotypes non seulement chez les
grandes personnes mais aussi chez les
plus jeunes
chez les plus jeunes ce que j'essaie de
le dire j'essaie de leur dire regardez
vous pouvez être quelqu'un d'accompli de
quelqu'un d'éduqué respectueux et de
passionnés sans forcément changer ce que
vous êtes et ce que vous aimez et aux
plus grands ce que j'essaie de leur dire
c'est de regarder la différence
autrement les gens peuvent ne pas
s'habiller comme nous ne pas parler
comme nous ne pèse dans le même univers
que nous mettons dans l'eure une petite
chance et les regardons pas mal dès le
début au contraire essayons de bâtir des
ponts entre nous une fois que j'ai fait
cela je dois vous dire que les cultures
urbaines certains d'entre vous ne savent
pas forcément ce que c'est on pourrait
définir sa de manière très simple dans
les années 60 des années 70 même dans
les années 50
nos pays les îles de la caraïbe sont
devenus de plus en plus urbanisée aux
états unis aulas avait commencé déjà
bien plus tôt mais les cultures urbaines
ce sont les modes d'expression les
manières de vivre les manière de
s'habiller les manières de produits un
qui sont issus de ce changement là qui
sont issus des personnes qui ont vécu
dans les milieux urbains
ces personnes dans les milieux urbains à
un moment donné elles ont mis en place
de nouvelles technologies
elles ont mis en place de nouvelles
manières de bouger de nouvelles manières
de faire de la musique de nouvelles
manières de faire du sport aussi je peux
vous donner quelques exemples
bon le rap on le connaît mieux c'est le
sommet de l'iceberg
le dancehall pour nous qui sort le
kingston la jamaïque on le connaît bien
ça va avec des manières de danser ça va
aussi avec une mode vestimentaire
ça va aussi avec un langage une manière
de parler de s'adresser aux gens ça va
aussi avec l'art visuel
l'art visuel c'est à dire des manières
de faire et documenté des manières de
produire des films
le contenu aussi et bien sûr je présente
plus le graff dont pac man est un
ambassadeur vraiment formidable le graff
il est présent un petit peu partout là
aussi tout ça on peut mettre ça dans les
cultures urbaines
on peut mettre aussi la manière de faire
du vélo le bmx certains d'entre eux vont
connu ça les manières de faire du vélo
on peut être dans certains sports de
glisse on peut même mettre dedans des
manières de faire du sport comme par
exemple le street ball le basket ou crp
un sport en salle aujourd'hui l'une des
récentes manifestations
c'est de voir des jeunes allaient dans
des équipements de la ville et fait un
des acrobaties sur les équipements de la
ville
tout ça on peut mettre ça dans le même
sac les cultures urbaines
j'ai appelé mon stock à l'aide les
cultures urbaines sont dans ma classe
pourquoi je l'a appelé comme ça c'est
parce que les souvent mes collègues
éducateur au collège au lycée est
maintenant dans les écoles primaires
mes collègues éducateurs voit les
cultures urbaines arriver non pas comme
de gentilles petites choses discrète
dans leur salle de cours
mais les cultures urbaines arrive dans
le en cours sans aucun respect pour land
établi
elle arrive soit avec une musique qui
forte il faut dire à chaque fois aux
élèves et aux écouteurs elle arrive des
fois avec un jean qui tombe là comme ça
et rentre en cours comme ça elle arrive
peut-être défend avec une manière de
s'habiller elle arrive aussi des fois
avec un vocabulaire
une manière de regarder les filles une
manière pour les filles de parle des
garçons et cultures urbaines arrive dans
un sale con sans respect pour l'ordre
établi et très souvent mes collègues et
du catr 10 c'est quoi ce truc ça pas sa
place
j'ai un problème avec ça et beaucoup de
collègues éducateurs beaucoup de
collègues infirmières autres me disent
on a un souci là on doit gérer les
problèmes de violence il faut que tu
viennes
parce qu'on a besoin d'avoir une
expertise l'idée que j'aimerais partager
avec vous elle est simple au lieu que ce
soit un problème
j'aurais aimé qu'on puisse en faire un
tremplin un moyen de passer du savoir de
passer des contenus pédagogiques c'est
possible pourquoi est ce que je dis ça
il nous faut commencer à penser un peu
comme ça parce qu'aujourd'hui les
cultures urbaines
elles ont déployé leurs filets partout
dans le monde
il y a une jeunesse il ya les gens de 15
à 50 ans qui sont influencés par ces
modes d'exposition c'est façon de
s'habiller ses façons de penser l'autre
un peu partout si vous et moi on part là
maintenant on prend l'avion et qu'on va
à cette pollution 20 castries on va
trouver les cultures urbaines en crée et
présente
si on veut un petit peu plus loin allez
disons qu'on va faire un tour au pérou
on vers l'amérique du sud
on les trouvera bien installé en va en
colombie on les trouvera un piédestal et
au chili
aussi je parle même pas du canada et les
états unis ils ont au concours puisque
sa sortie la halle et on veut en europe
où on va en suède
on les trouvera là on va à londres même
chose la france du nord au sud
même chose on descend en espagne elles
sont présentes sous plusieurs formes et
les pratiquants et les admirateurs et
les gens qui ne les aime pas du tout qui
ne les côtoie pas mais qui quelque part
en simple influencé par n donc elles ont
une espèce de puissance que on ne peut
plus ignorer les forces économiques
les industries culturelles ont déjà
compris leur puissance lorsqu'elle
cherche à vendre des événements
lorsqu'un chien j'invente des marques de
vêtements
lorsqu'elle cherche à vendre des
boissons alcoolisées ou non elles font
appel aux cultures urbaines
parce qu'elles savent qu'elles sont très
puissantes et qu'elles peuvent toucher
une catégorie de personnes qui peuvent
leur apporter de l'argent elles l ont
compris leur puissance les forces
économiques par exemple aller en vain à
trinidad et j'ai rencontré à trinidad
marchand de meubles qui pour pouvoir
faire venir des clients à utiliser du
rap pour pouvoir faire venir des clients
dans son magasin on peut aller un autre
endroit tient alors un des trois à
detroit j'ai rencontré là cette fois ci
une grosse industrie automobile qui a
utilisé la réputation et le talent d'un
rappeur qui s'appelle eminem pour
pouvoir vendre des marques de voitures
et ils n'ont pas faire n'importe quel
moment ils ont fait un moment donné où
l'industrie automobile après la crise de
2008 était complètement plombé
ils ont fait appel à la force de ses
expressions là pour pouvoir attirer les
clients parce qu'ils savent ils ont
reconnu leur puissance il ya une autre
chose qui me fut voir leur puissance et
que les expressions des cultures
urbaines
elle change la manière dont certaines
personnes voient le monde
la manière dont elle considère la
sexualité par exemple la manière dont
elles vont considérer ce qui est
important dans la vie où ce qui n'est
pas important du tout et les gens qui
vous diront à cause de ce monde là ils
vous diront ça enrichit réserve
obligeant à ouais tu vois plus et ça
c'est mon rêve mon gars initialisé mais
tout ça à partir de ses fils et là il ya
des hommes qui regardent les femmes à
partir des lunettes que les cultures
urbaines leurs jeunes et les femmes qui
considèrent aussi ce que c'est qu'un
homme viril
à partir de ces expressions là et ça
peut toucher en plein show ça peut
toucher aussi au rôle de l'éducation ça
peut toucher aussi à l'estimé de soi
qu'est ce qui me donne de la valeur
qu'est-ce qu'il fait chez quelqu'un
d'important les cultures urbaines
elles ont une réponse pour beaucoup de
jeunes personnes peu importe leurs
communautés ethniques
peu importe leur religion peu importe
leur préférence sexuelle
peu importe où ils habitent dans le
monde ici regardez c'est un graffeur qui
s'appelle than les martiniquais
c'est magnifique il a su inscrire son
nom dans un mur de la ville
vous avez reconnu spike lee à partir de
ce que nous sommes
oui c'est un geste parce que c'est
comment exactement mais il inscrit sa
dans son patrimoine caribéen
et il nous a mis en relation directe
avec la communauté afro américaine mais
aussi avec tous ceux qui aiment le
graphe cette photo-là el hadj a été
regardée des millions de fois partout
elle est partie d'agrafés aux
martiniquais ici le photographe c'est
moi avec un portable mais j'étais à
cette manifestation la le danseur ici là
le bboy le breaker je ne connais ici en
martinique
c'est très bon danseur il y avait un
rassemblement où là j'étais avec mes
filles mais le personnes autour ça se
passe à fort de france et une place
celle qui est connue de tous les poppers
et près de 10 et à fort de france ici
regardez
très souvent les cultures urbaines on
les voit comme des monde machiste
sexiste c'est à dire où la femme est
réduit à ses capacités sexuelles ou à
les rédui simplement à son sexe ou à les
dénigrer
parce que c'est une fin c'est une
réalité que j'ai c'est de combattre
aussi et qu'il nous faut combattre
mais ce sont des mondes qui laisse la
place à plein de gens différents
tu peux être musulman chrétien athée
juif tu peux sortir de jérusalem du plus
sentir et brice importe d'où tu viens
comme il disait tout à l'heure bachmann
ghettos ou château tu as ta place à part
du moment où j'ai du talent ici 1
vous voyez cette graffeuse là j'oublie
son pays mais voyait très asiatique
ici on aime piqueur ya les femmes qui
pratiquent la danse et qui pratiquent
d'autres expressions dans issus des
cultures urbaines et qui le font très
bien
certaines fois certaines manifestations
on s'en fiche hausse avant c'était un
homme une femme
tout ce qu'on veut savoir ce qu'est ce
que tu as dans le ford avec wade venu
montre nous ce que tu sais faire
peu importe ici c'est une graff sénégal
est ce parce que les cultures urbaines
chose et ils sont installés aussi dans
presque tout le continent africain
l'afrique du nord maroc algérie tunisie
aussi revenons à notre affaire
les cultures urbaines et l'éducation je
vous entends jusqu'à maintenant bon fait
que je vous ai convaincu jusqu'à
maintenant parce que oui oui mais il y
en a qui se demande doit être une
histoire à la whey ça roule bien
west vancouver mais finalement qui
gérera fait comment est ce que tu fais
comment est ce que tu fais pour utiliser
ça pour enseigner à des gens je peux
vous donner peut-être quelques pistes
que j'ai déjà mis en action et que
d'autres collègues éducateurs et
éducatrices ont mis en action
ça peut être des matières très
différentes ça va de la géographie en
passant par la littérature
on peut aller jusqu à l'éducation
civique et pourquoi pas aussi
l'éducation physique le ps commençons
par le ps humains socialiste mais l'un
de mes collègues j'ai rencontrées sur le
terrain m'a dit que pour pouvoir motiver
ses élèves à bouger et à rentrer dans
les activités sportives
il a décidé d'utiliser la musique qu'il
aimait la musique que ses élèves
écoutez à longueur de journée et croyez
le ou pas sa fonction
je connais une de mes collègues qui
travaillent sur deux lycées en
martinique la travailler dans le célèbre
lycée chez le chien qui a accueilli aimé
césaire et elle m'a dit que elle elle
enseigne la littérature les lettres
modernes elle m'a dit qu'elle est passée
elle par les textes de rap pour pouvoir
enseigner le romantisme à ses élèves
je me rends compte en le disant
b elle a réussi c'est à dire que l est
les spécialistes du romantisme et elle
est aussi spécialiste de ce qu'elle doit
enseigner à ses élèves elle sait vers
quoi elle doit le faire avoir mais entre
le curriculum et comment arriver c'est
là que la liberté les cultures urbaines
arrive et elle a utilisé les textes de
rappeurs qui faisait appel à des notions
qui parlait d'amour
qui faisait appel à des notions qui lui
permettait de ramener ses élèves vers le
romantisme et vers l'évolution du
romantisme
croyez le ou pas expérience vécue elle y
est arrivée
je peux vous donner encore un autre
exemple pourquoi pas passer par les
expressions des cultures urbaines pour
enseigner les langues étrangères
ça a été prouvé on a quelqu'un qui est
ici en guadeloupe il ya de cela environ
2/3 ans il a montré par a plus b comment
est ce que la musique pouvait aider les
gens à apprendre une langue étrangère
je suis sûr que cette idée là elle est
déjà parmi vous passez par certains
textes musiques et certaines ambiances
pour pouvoir enseigner l'espagnol
l'anglais et pourquoi pas peut-être pas
l'enseigné de la même manière mais aussi
passer certaines choses dans notre
langue à noah créole
pourquoi pas sachant qu'un il y a les
artistes aujourd'hui créolophones qui
sont comme des apôtres pour le plus
jeune que ça soit les jeunes qui sont
scolarisés les jeunes qui sont en
liberté
normaux et les jeunes aussi qui sont
déscolarisés et les jeunes qui sont
incarcérés
est ce qu'on va laisser la puissance de
ses musiques et de ses expressions aux
forces économiques à des choses qui
peuvent être difficiles où le vivre
ensemble
où est ce qu'on va tenter le voir mais
comment est-ce qu'on peut nous
éducateurs trouver notre place et
pourquoi pas entre guillemets jeudi
entre guillemets utiliser la puissance
qu'elle développe une autre chose que je
vous dirais aujourd'hui c'est que si on
ne pense pas autrement
l'éducation on ne pourra pas relever les
défis qui sont devant nous si vous
regardez bien on a touché le fond
les titres des médias aujourd'hui nous
montre qu'on a touché le fond donc
pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas faire autrement penser
autrement pourquoi pas essayer
maintenant ça c'est un défi pour nous et
éducateurs éducatrices parce que c'est
un défi parce que lorsqu'on se décident
pourquoi pas exploré ce chemin là on va
se retrouver à ne plus être
expert souvent qu'on rentre nos salles
de cours nous sommes les experts
on a fait les études peau on n'a plus
l'homme pont et on est les experts de la
connaissance qui à transmettre
mais là si on décide de passer par ce
chemin là ça veut dire que nos élèves
nos apprenants
ils auront une petite longueur avance
sur nous et ça nous fait devenir
peut-être un peu vulnérable mais
l'éducateur progressiste c'est quelqu'un
qui ne refuse pas d'être vulnérable
c'est quelqu'un qui s'éduque lui-même
avant éduquer les autres c'est important
pour nous de faire cela maintenant si on
n'arrive pas à faire cela
j'ai l'impression que les choses ne vont
pas forcément changé ce n'est pas le
seul remède c'est pas le seul mais c'est
l'un des romains de qu'on peut utiliser
le dr king que pac-man inciter tout à
l'heure et aussi un modèle pour moi
c'est une référence
c'est une référence parce que c'est un
homme qui est pétri par la foi
chrétienne mais qui n'a pas utilisé la
foi chrétienne pour se réfugier dans un
espèce de nirvana non il a utilisé pour
pouvoir changer transformer le monde un
pays où des jeunes aiment éduquer m
l'éducation veulent continuer à aller
plus loin c'est un pays qui sera plus
fort merci